what's our first bet okay the first bet
so there will be a Billboard top 100
song created by AI a billboard yes top
100 song created by AI yes
okay okay now what I'm going to do is we
just don't want to do predictions I'm
going to show you the latest in AI lyric
and song creation and to give us a
little warmup here to level set where
we're at and how much further we'd have
to go and we're going to talk a little
bit about what happened earlier in the
year as well so and we don't think
there's been one already because if you
told me there's been one and one of the
Grimes mashups had made it I would have
not I would have believed it but I don't
think one has because we would know that
yeah and I don't think it it it it went
into the top 100 got it so it has to be
in the top 100 and it has to be 100%
created by AI not this is you know
Taylor Swift and then they do a little
AI on it it's an AI artist or an AI
representation of would the AI
representation of Grimes count I think
it would yeah we're we're going to allow
that to be part that that's okay that's
sufficient if someone takes an AI voice
and so I think we have Nick on with us
Nick you have uh just for a quick recap
let's go backwards the AI Drake uh
collaboration can you throw that on for
us Nick yeah so this is from earlier in
this year remember there was a song hard
on my sleeve that everybody thought was
real and this was sort of in the early
stages of generative AI where people
kind of confused about if Drake actually
did this or not and here's just a video
this isn't the person who made it but
here's just the guy basically recreating
how they did it uh very simply vocals
she know what she need oh I need oh she
bless uploading those vocals to an AI
generator she know what she
need a
DS autotune artist making sure that he's
in key some light Reverb on top so this
is the final result my heart on my
sleeve and the knife in my back was with
that he 21 I love him that's my brother
I kind of like producer baay I know I
mean what's up with producer baay that
guy should be I mean he's handsome he's
got the accent and he's got I mean do
you see his hand eye coordination the
speed at which he's editing that stuff
yeah man producer AI B has got potential
man he's got to drop some more tracks so
what you're saying here Kenway by the
way is his name Kenway shout up that was
six months ago right so that was H you
know so that's what you know it's out
there people have figured out how to do
it anybody can it's indistinguishable
it's indistinguishable today so let's
just put that out there so it's
indistinguishable so what we're really
betting on
here is and I guess I'll go first on
this one you first on before we no no
before we one more piece of evidence
here okay no at the end of last year
exactly because we gotta have yeah it's
okay well produced yeah you're very
excited this awesome so at the end of
last year just a couple of weeks ago a
week ago sun. was released and they
already have their own trending list
like you would see in a um Spotify
Spotify exactly and you know people have
created different you know obviously
there's a Christmas toe up here here's a
Bluegrass inspirational Lively and so
I'll just kind of rewind this back and
hit
[Music]
play okay and so what this does is you
can create and what I did and I'm just
going to keep going forward here I
actually uh made a Paw Patrol drill rap
song and so that was my uh my prompt was
using the characters of Paw Patrol make
a you know breaking all copyright
violations here you got the PAW Patrol
IP you've got whatever
artist 50 in here I love it and so I'm
gonna play this and let's go back here
just
this we got the fame we a Miss we never
back down just rush we run this down We
Heroes never been in qu
okay so oh yeah man I can see kids
digging that yeah and so again U now
we've gone from what the um we saw in
the YouTube video where you you had to
at least you know put the lyrics in
yourself write the lyrics this is all
just prompt based yes the music is
prompt and the lyrics are also generated
just on a theme full service here AI
what we call AI all the way down all the
way down got it yeah so that's what we
have you can do sort of be really
bespoke or you can say type in prompts
there's a Spotify one of those songs
makes it into the top 100 over under
July 1st right okay so I'm going to take
the over now let me explain why okay
it's clearly this is easily technical
technically possible in fact it's
probable and in fact we probably could
have had a Billboard 100 in the last
year or so so what you have to
understand when making this bet this is
my thinking behind the bat now wait have
you picked your choice over or under
well no what we're going to do is you
got to go first so next time I get to go
first so okay so I have to take the
other okay great so okay so you have the
under by default I took the over over
the reason it's the over and the reason
I'll win this one hands down is because
nothing happens in the music industry
without the music industry making it
happen this is an industry it's kind of
like China right like they they'll
decide what the REM andb is they'll
decide the stock price they'll decide
inflation they'll decide get yeah
everything is decided by the people in
charge so the music industry
runs like a communist country or you
know any other you know dictatorship so
the music industry you'd have to ask
would they want this would they want it
now I think the music industry is a
little scared of doing this right now
and opening up this can of worms with
artists so the only way this could
happen is if a true artist like tlor
Swift um who has more leverage over the
music platforms than the platforms have
over her right so how many artists have
more power than the music industry
itself it's Taylor Swift it's Jay-Z It's
Beyonce and you you could tell this
because remember Beyonce Jay-Z and
Taylor Swift all took the music off of
Spotify at different points in time to
make a point yeah so I don't know who
else is in that rarified error but I
think it's those three so unless one of
those three says I'm putting out this AI
Jay-Z track and I don't think Jay-Z
would ever do it I don't think Beyonce
would ever do it and I don't think teror
Swift would ever do it unless they were
doing it as some sort of a goof or proof
of concept so I think the m and I don't
think the music industry is ready for
this um because it would create all
kinds of Union issues contract issues uh
and other things that would trigger
artists to not want to participate in
the music industry or it just creates a
fight and and tension that they don't
want smoke they don't want yet so that's
why I'm picking the over and that's why
I'm going to win $1,000 doll okay well
I'm going to take the under because
think about remember Rebecca Black
Friday yes that that kind of one hit
wonder and we have those all the time
and I think given these tools someone
will create at least a one one hit
wonder to begin with that'll get into
the top 100 this year so I'm actually
okay with the under on this one okay
that's fine you think that the music
industry actually that that 100 list is
not picked and sorted over by the music
industry you think you could actually
break into it it can be an independ an
independent song right it doesn't have
to be on a label yeah any song the
Billboard 100 the Billboard 100 though I
think is bought and paid for it that's
all I'm saying I don't have evidence of
that I just this is like a Tony Soprano
kind of situation how did re I think
they let her on I think they let her on
I think anybody gets on that list it's
because they let them on I think it's
you can look at the history of the music
industry giv us a little bit of the
inside I don't know see I don't know
that side of the world there but okay I
think it's like one of these the few
remaining industries that is run by a
cartel okay and from what I understand
from friends of mine who are in the
music industry and you can look up
stories of people putting guns to
people's heads and sign over these
royalties and we should get Rob Goldberg
on for an episode cuz he knows this
stuff really music I just think the
music industry is still like one of the
few remaining gangster esque driven
Industries that's why I'm picking the
but I could be wrong who knows okay
awesome great so I'm good with the and
with to me all right okay awesome all
right so we're done the first one yum
Founders always ask me for pitch deck
punch-ups how do I make my pitch deck a
little better well I've got some great
news for you we work with the team at
Miro uh you know like hero Miro m i r o
that awesome whiteboarding software I've
told you all about and when we worked
with them to create an amazing pitch
deck template for Founders which you can
see if you're watching the video right
now or if you're listening you can see
this pitch deck at mirro.com moverse and
do a search for pitch deck M o.com
moverse m i r o v r s e I want you to go
check this out because our founder
University of participants they love
this template they use it all the time
and so go ahead and check out that pitch
deck template you're going to love it
and if your team is hybrid or fully
remote Meo is incredibly useful for you
because it's like an old school
whiteboarding session you know those
great ones but this one is distributed
in a synchronous lets everybody
brainstorm ideas collaborate on projects
from anywhere in the world this software
is so popular and when you think of Miro
I want you to think of zero to one but
faster if you get all those ideas out on
your whiteboard with Miro you're going
to have all kinds of creative
breakthroughs and it's hard to do
creative breakthroughs when you're just
in text so mirro is much more than just
a simple digital whiteboard your team
can collaborate on on everything
planning research design feedback cycles
and faster inputs equals faster outcomes
and velocity is how startups win so to
access our new Miro verse template and
thousands of others sign up today for a
free Muro account at mirro.com startups
m.com startups that's mirror.com
startups to sign up for free